you know you said something about star
wars the star wars guy did you did you
audition for star wars
you know it's the it's this internet uh
uh yeah
they throw that out there well it's the
internet screws up it's like that dixie
cup with a string in it
the way they uh kind of obstruct the
truth no
i have a great uh once upon a time in
hollywood story
that i tell it conventions and it got
turned into robert england was up for
star wars
i was i wanted to go in and audition
for the frederick forest role in
apocalypse now
the chef quickly i was too young
and freddie forrest was under contract
to the zodiac trope
but i got in for the surfer because
i had done big wednesday because i surf
so they brought me in for the surfer
they thought i was a little bit too old
i had
kind of you know stubbly beard but i was
buff i was
tan i was surfing i had long blonde hair
and i was wearing kind of a military
uh thrift shop outfit apocalypse now
right
i think i even had a pair of fake dog
tags on my shirt unbuttoned
long blonde curly hair and fred's
fred bruce or somebody walked me across
the hall
from the apocalypse now audition which
which i did not get
they said you know you might be right
for something here and they brought me
over to the star wars audition
and i don't even think it was called
star wars then
and they took my polaroid like a mug
shot
you know profile and full face and i
think it was for the han solo role i
think they
didn't they didn't know how to go with
it originally they were thinking of an
older uncle the kind of guy that brings
a joint to thanksgiving
and gets all the kids high you know the
cool older uncle and then
and i think they even offered it to tom
seller i think i heard
and he turned them down or something i
don't know but anyway he turned it down
for reform
for a reverse mortgage
yeah back in the day little annie's
husband passed away
she loved her house though she didn't
want to lose her house anyway
i've i've been around the block saying
my first rodeo anyway
i go across the hall and it's and and
i'm
just excited because i love george lucas
american graffiti
thx 138 i love george lucas i go across
the hall i take my polaroid maybe for
han solo but i notice the sides for luke
skywalker
because the name it's such a great name
luke skywalker
and i looked at the sides i can't
remember if i stole them or not
i went across the street to the formosa
so now you know where i am oh yeah had a
couple of bushmills
jumped in my old 2000 datsun
not year 2000 cubic inches and i went
went back to my place in laurel canyon
and i look outside there's a pair of
old beat up fry boots in front of my
front door which means ah
it's mark hamill because we would take
off our shoes i had nice carpeting in my
my lair up in laurel canyon and uh
mark was on my couch watching the bob
newhart show
we would watch bob newhart and mary
tyler moore because we hadn't watched
the originals
then we'd call our agents and i walked
in the door and i said hey mark you know
you
george lucas is doing another movie and
you might be right for this
so my my once upon a time in hollywood
story
is that freddy krueger told luke
skywalker
to call his agent and he got the part
you know he got in there and got the
part
now his agent hates me telling this
story because she swears that
she already had submitted him but i
don't know of course
this is before your time but in the 70s
you were either movies or you were tv
you didn't go back and forth
until travolta oh yeah um until welcome
back cotter
and then he went into saturday night
fever right that was a big shift that
was a big shift you were either a movie
guy
or a tv guy and your agents had power
accordingly